[Music]
in do your part news submitted by boba
martini I've had one of those it's
actually not that bad and the boba gets
you [ __ ] up because it soaks upon your
party there's both alcohol yeah it was
good a federal program says you should
keep your home's temperature above 78
degrees oh yeah 78 degrees you fall
asleep with that [ __ ] yes oh witness you
can sign up for this thing called rush
hour and they give you money back so
during rush hour they kind of control
that setting so it just changes like if
you guys have an S it'll change and it
turns yellow and that's to let you know
that it's like it's programmed to what
their settings which is 78 plus [ __ ]
ha is override it no they look at
moneybags
oh [ __ ] before the rush program they
change it to 73
well I enrolled us in that you dick 78
like I like a 75 for my looks so that's
pretty warm that's good my perfect is 73
me too 78 is like it's summer and then
you're turning on the heater to make it
warmer in the house that's true because
why what the hell's going on I like that
we have temperature is this a [ __ ]
blame we are we have designated
temperatures for ourselves no it's lame
that it [ __ ] 3 in the summer we
wanted in the 60s during the winter we
want it in like the 70s and we don't
even have to change it that much I'm
already warm body dude don't [ __ ] with
me government what's it so do you guys
have to keep the house super cold all
the time cuz you yeah it's not even that
cold it's 73 I prefer like 77 73 is not
cool nah you don't keep it at 73 I do at
home I do really yeah a little over the
wife whatever the wife wants I support I
only allow him 72 dude the air
conditioners like right over Nicki's
office so just blow the hair right and
and then like I'm all the way downstairs
and so are the man no it doesn't matter
cuz it's still week she eats it okay
heat rises so she's gonna be mega [ __ ]
alright but it goes pretty nuts in there
and so so by the time it gets to me
downstairs like I'm like diagonally
opposite to that in the house I barely
feel it and so I'm and then did
sometimes Nikki comes in my oh geez and
I'm like oh it's okay baby okay why
don't you switch offices yeah cuz that's
the better office having seen the office
nice location and she she has almost did
sunlight in there and I [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] I'm in like a cave it's
perfect do you a little damp in there
dungeon are you yeah that's the part
that sucks ass
the litter box the washer dryer it's all
in there the boxes are and all the [ __ ]
she's trying to throw away yeah way to
make it personal Jesus no in our home
cuz there's so many levels like we had
like the garage which doesn't matter but
then like the the living room is one
level of the dining rooms another level
and then upstairs with the bed another
level so upstairs it was always so hot
like I
we couldn't even breathe like it's
[ __ ] hot and we have the a/c set to
like 69 sometimes where's the a/c come
out of downstairs yeah so there's this
huge vent in the kitchen so in the
middle one and that's where the [ __ ]
thermostat is so like immediately a
bullet thinks that it's cooler but
upstairs it's super hot so then just
recently we asked our landlord to change
the event because we couldn't close the
vent so like move the air other places
and so we recently changed it and now
are in our whole house is like one
temperature because now I'm like I'm
messing with all the vents and because
sometimes like if the office one is open
then it gets really warm upstairs
because it's the offices upstairs but
then if I close that one it'll get too
cold so I'm like trying to like finesse
all the events and like especially with
the outside temperature and like how it
affects the house does at home no wonder
you're so tired I'm always tired I can
never get good
sometimes I take a cold shower just
because it's so [ __ ] hot those
feelings they feel really good
do you remember your old [ __ ] bedroom
how hot it gets me I'll never forget I
warned you yeah my war news no central
a/c and I warned you about that and at
that time you were into bath bombs and I
said the prior would you take a bath
in the back like it's the worst yeah
like you know the water dispensers like
that the coolers whatever that water
pressures better than the bathtub that's
horrible
I didn't have AC for two [ __ ] days
and I was miserable and I didn't think
to hold you in here at Pasadena house
yeah like that so I have their room now
and there's like a little AC unit we
[ __ ] in against every wall there yeah
and the ceiling I made sure to look
every wall that doesn't bother me if I
knew that you guys [ __ ] all over my
whole house I'd be like that's tight
yeah all right me too I think I'd be
that's tidy but then I'm like I'm not a
weirdo like TIFF I don't know yeah
everywhere survived in that room because
the a/c is literally set on the low
setting 62 and a barely good like it
gets cool enough but sometimes I want it
cold I don't know how the [ __ ] you lived
in there do you change like the you
killed us I clean the filter yeah but
then like the back wall where your bed
was to like when the Sun beats on that
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] heater so why did
this is man conversation with 30 year
olds why do they recommend 78 like
energy-efficient right is that the
reason why what why yes because I'm just
dying to know why the [ __ ] so hot yeah
all right like who's gonna the answer
Joe come on and it's not even just seven
this is at 70 to 85 or something exactly
guidelines from Energy Star which is a
government backed program to promote
energy efficiency [ __ ] up and so they
said agreed so this is a guideline this
is what it looks like their homes better
be like this you beat me so it says set
your thermostat as high also it says
operate your thermostat efficiently Sega
thermostat as high as comfortably
possible in the summer the smaller the
difference between the indoor and
outdoor temperatures the lower your
overall cooling bill will be so this
whole thing is like to have a lower bill
mmm if you want the lowest Villages turn
off your AC yeah stupid having your
house at 85 is just
same [ __ ] unless you're in Boston Las
Vegas or something exactly is that keep
your house warmer than normal when you
are away and lower the thermostat
setting to 78 degrees only when you are
at home and need cooling 78 degrees when
you need cooling at home at home a
programmable thermostat can make it easy
to set back your temperature
another one is avoid setting your
thermostat at a colder setting than
normal when you turn on your air
conditioner it will not cool your home
any faster and could result in excessive
cooling and unnecessary expense that one
was those uh useful I think because
sometimes like if you if your house is
so [ __ ] hot you'll put it to like 61
just so if you like blasted so yeah
there's this is an example of how you
should be setting your thermostat the
schedule I want to go to their house
yeah that's the thing these people all
millionaires they all have sick ass AC
units they just want to tell us all of
us plans how to live that's the [ __ ]
that drives me nuts yes it says when you
wake up at 6 a.m. am i these two or is
the study at 6 a.m. right for heat the
setting point is 70 degrees Fahrenheit
the cool is 78 now [ __ ] you at 8 a.m.
set back at least 8 degrees Fahrenheit
for Fahrenheit for heat set at least 7
degrees for cool 6 p.m. 70 degrees for
heat 78 for cool panic again
yeah 70 is fine that's a nice that's for
heat though yeah for heat that's what I
said in the summer I mean the ones who
are like and this is for California
specifically no it's just for cuz
federal law cannot imagine going to
Texas where it's humid in 78 oh I think
it's 90 I don't even have a use for
heaters here in California or like in LA
like I don't even know why we need a
heater you're not really shitty
insulation you need it can get that when
I used to live in k-town
during wintertime one time my heater was
broken I could see my breath in my own
apartment yeah but you just got a layer
up you wear like three sweaters I didn't
jump in your [ __ ] bed that shitty
person were like I don't want to layer
up so I just blast the heaters off
like somewhere in my house in the winter
you are shitty yeah they say that I
think it's probably worse but yeah if
you do this you'll save 180 dollars a
year you all back you save 100 bucks a
year suffering if I am trying to save a
hundred and eighty dollars a year if I
need to save that much money I'm turning
off the AC completely and I'm even gonna
move and turn off the lights just use
candles yeah that's like not even my
monthly monster budget is responsible
yeah but thank you I like that that's
why it so congested here cuz you have
great weather and people are trying to
leave the shitty weather to come to LA
and people think they can make it here
there's jobs here they can make it Jeana
I want them to make it I used to go
visit my grandparents in Asia in the
summer and it's really hot it's like 200
maybe 120 and the humidity is insane and
I would try to turn on the a/c but
they're so old school I don't want to
work and he just has a fan my grandpa
just a [ __ ] fan like this well yeah
yes just to it though I think yeah we're
used to the a/c so then I was there for
a month I'm just staring at my grandpa
and there's just sweat just coming down
like like I'm ready for breakfast and
I'm just [ __ ] polish this point on my
face we went they never used the a/c
they're sweating all over everything and
they're super chill about it and honors
how they live they get used to it maybe
crazy you know that's how rich you are
even more people in our [ __ ] country
have AC in their apartments and that's
how rich we and on average they usually
have a car yeah that's crazy
that's crazy that's poor in the u.s.
having a car and AC that's insane Wow
way to put things into perspective why
are we complaining about this [ __ ] I
mean that's great well that's who has we
have [ __ ] like this where we're like how
dare they try to affect my life
my guess is the kind of [ __ ] we [ __ ]
about you that's that's pretty tight
I'll [ __ ] about this is like [ __ ]
forever if I get a bigger I'm down and
that's what makes this country great job
according to the National Sleep
Foundation we even have a National Sleep
Foundation right wheel I need to go
there so bad dude how the [ __ ] much
money on these guys getting by the way
can we just give this money to poor
people or something well there's no
Sleep Foundation is [ __ ] failing
because there's a there's a lot of
insomnia problems happening yeah can we
dissolve the National Sleep Foundation
and give it to the homeless yeah because
they've been [ __ ] around for a while
but they've been sucking these days
everyone so they're saying that all
right I would want to try to sleep study
things like I want them to study me see
what the hell's going on sleep or I
don't think of a problem sleeping do you
know what's going on the other night the
girls to see me messaging them at like
8:00 in the morning they're like you
haven't slept having you so the other
day I didn't sleep the whole night
I fell asleep around 1:30 p.m. and woke
up at 3:30 p.m. and then stayed up the
whole night again and now I'm here Wow
maybe we should stop drinking coffee I
like 11:00 p.m. no I don't drink coffee
at all
maybe you need a [ __ ] POG glass of
water and a good old dick oh I've been
chugging water and then go on before we
end the video I just want to mention
that points to National Sleep Foundation
a room somewhere around 65 degrees makes
for the best when it's cool it feels
good and you're like bundle of good in a
winter y'all know the National Sleep
Foundation statements put me to [ __ ]
sleep yeah
[Applause]
[Music]